hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast education and training from
knowledge acquisition to continuous
professional development
I'm Robert Castellanos of lab rats and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is a leading scientific
social networking website and producers
educational virtual events and webinars
contributing to the advancement of
science through content sharing
capabilities lab leads is a powerful
advocate and amplifying global networks
and communities we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge a slide window by clicking
on the screen icon and the lower
right-hand corner of the window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I'd like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Marcel guider dr.
Marcel Geiger is currently the chairman
of the Regional ethical review board for
animal experimentation in Lausanne
Switzerland having received his PhD in
the bioacoustics of rodents from the
University of lizanne he's went on to
complete his postdoctoral work in the
communication of birds at Rockefeller
University and the somatosensory
neurobiology of the mouse at the
University of Lausanne he served as a
president of the Swiss society of
laboratory animal science from 2004 to
2013 and beginning of January 2017 he'll
be the falsa vice president for the
education training I'll now turn it over
to dr. Marcel Geiger for his
presentation Hey thank you very much
this nice introduction and I thank very
much the the noise ecology
the roots to have invited me for this
presentation of education and training
from knowledge acquisition to continuous
professional development and test for
background of my talk I would like to
say that the view the perspective is
very European oriented and also with the
fellows our perspective and so there are
two learning outcomes to this talk the
first one is really to try to understand
and to describe the European education
and training system and to have also a
view on the fellows education and
training accreditation process and the
second one we mean concentrate on the
CPD on the continuous professional
development and I will give you some
information on the fellows of you and I
finally will end the talk with an
example of CPD system in Switzerland so
let's start with the education and
training in Europe and here I will
subdivide my cloak in three parts just
mentioning the directive and then two
other very important documents that I
will develop in the later slides so
first the directive 2010 / 60 people
came in force in 2010 at the level of
the Bureau and then there were some
years about 2 to 3 years for the
national legislation to adapt to this
directing and the aim of the directed at
least for education and training was to
put it as mandatory in each member state
therefore to harmonize education and
training to ensure that competence is in
place meaning that the quality of the
course should be behind and this
of course when facilitate free movements
of personal between the countries which
is quite important in Switzerland in the
research community and this is based on
article 23 of the directive on
competence of personnel and the second
part of this article mentioned that the
staff shall be adequately educated and
trained before they perform any of the
tolling functions
carrying out procedures on this function
designing procedures and project this is
function be taking care of animals and
cincy or finally function D killing
animals so Europe has subdivide that
animal experimentation in four basic
category taking care of the animals
applying for serious designing projects
and the fourth one which is killing
animals this especially dedicated to
people working on primary cell culture
things like that there's only directed
some expert working groups were set up
in education and training they are
produced document which is named a
working document on the development of
the common education and training
framework to qualify the requirement
under the directive this was finished in
2013 and then it was amended and finally
accepted by the NCA meaning the national
competent authorities which endorsed
this paper February 2015 and I will go
now in some details about this working
document which is about 80 to 90 pages
within a fairly good description all of
the scheme but before that I will just
like to remind people that fellows are
made a fantastic pioneer work starting
in 1995
describing four categories of competence
and in 2002 fellows are published an
excitation paper on animal science
education training courses and the aim
was clearly two days to have a common
basis for organization of education for
those working with and the field of Alex
of animal experimentation was subdivided
in four categories in the next slide and
[Music]
published in a division of technicians
[Music]
so this is not a very important slide
between the specialist animal
disappeared in VDU function that was
replaced by some other role I designated
that we see the article 25 the animal
welfare officer 1 / a project evaluator
is another important function because so
what is also very important is that the
framework is based on model training
structure and concentrating on learning
outcomes in these in those paper the
learning process very roughly about
describe going from acquisition of
knowledge when people are entering the
field of animal exploitation and other
animal sciences they acquire practice
and experience then they will go into
more deeper learning critical thinking
of what they are doing to reach full
competence and there are two paths of
training in the middle you see that the
training is done without working
directly with the I know they have to
pass an exam and then they work under
supervision and then to acquire and
maintain the skills these are the people
who may potentially inflict pain
distress to animals so these are clearly
people applying procedures involved here
on the lower part of the slide you will
see training because working under
supervision before passing the exam
these are really the animal caretaker
basis function C so here we don't think
that the tasks involved will inflict
pain - ok so there are just a separation
between this
to talk of Education and the working
group was also interested to going to
more deep thinking of educational
objectives and they used a pretty old
taxonomy Bloom's taxonomy which 50 60s
where you will go to full competence by
acquiring knowledge starting to Cooper
to to understand what you are doing to
apply it to analyze this synthases and
finally evaluating what you are doing
yourself and there are some descriptive
way to to describe these learning
outcomes this was so I think there are
between the fellows our paradigm
starting in the early 2000 years and the
directive there is a change of paradigm
in animal science teaching and clearly
the directive and those paper is
concentrating now on the output of the
learning outcome instead of process of
looking at the number of hours the
topics they are covered etc so the
learning outcomes describe what the
students should know should understand
to achieve after having attended a
specific module and so learning outcome
do not represent the course I love also
list of topics to be covered so there's
quite an important change of thinking of
how you will design a course and how do
we evaluate the people which in spite of
course is key and so there are three
quality criteria for a training module
is that you have to describe the
learning outcomes in details you know
what what is gained as heretical
knowledge what are the practical skills
to be achieved to be obtained by the
participant can you have to define how
you will assess the people
how you will decide if the people pass
or fail these examinations all that
she's got basic educational program but
this is fairly new in the way that they
patient education and training is in
Europe and also the module structure is
something like new in Europe children is
that we have different kind of modules
that people have go through to achieve
at least a basic knowledge and then to
go to full competence there are core
modules and these are really the basic
theoretical training this is the basis
for all functions a to D and this is of
course concern to me and then depending
on what your role will be in an
explantation you will attend specific
function which we deliver minimum
training for a specific function and on
top of this you may have additional
tasks specific models like example if
you're working as a function a person
applying proceedings were working in
bioimaging you have to achieve long
anesthesia of your animals then you will
attend specific modules on anesthesia
and Ibiza and also principle of surgery
for example and there are other
additional modules and of course what is
very also very important these modules
are species specific oriented so we will
have to attend for mayor for mice and
rats a kind of a course after having a
change course if you need to work on
zebrafish then you will attend some
specific species modules devoted to our
zebra tissues here very complex table
which are probably you cannot read but
this is a short list of the different
modules that you have oil can
on the the right side you have the email
function described CD a and B and then
you have a column clicking where
species-specific teaching has to be
given what is interesting here is that
you have to attend the five the six core
modules which are mandatory and then on
top of this you may add some more
function specific modules like basic and
appropriate biology the skills minimally
invasive proceedings without anesthesia
the theory and the skill and add union
methods of killing still oriented module
and by designing such course but it can
do is to deliver a course where people
going for function a C and D can attend
this course which gives you a pretty
large array of participants which gives
you also some freedom to design your
course in multiple ways and I just spent
three or four slides on the skill
teaching so moany
the three true is devoted to handing and
strength and here the description of the
learning outcome means to be able to
throw channel pick up and strain an
animal to return it to its cage planned
in a very relaxed way and padded manner
so in order that the animal is not
distressed after descending and restrain
for model a which is related to
minimally invasive procedures without
anesthesia you have here three learning
outcomes I don't want to go into the
details but it shows that you will have
to do to perform minor techniques under
supervision in a manner that does not
include unnecessary pain suffering
distress and the last one
six-two which is a skill teaching of you
to learning outcomes proficiency and you
mainly carry out in it inertia using
appropriate technique on relevant
species of lab animals and to
demonstrate how that is confirmed and
have the knowledge should be processed
or our disposal so this raised the
question of using live animals during
lab animal science courses which has
been quite often discussed in different
countries in Europe and the directive is
quite clear on this that the expert
group confident to use animals for the
purpose of Education and Professional
vocational skills in the U is acceptable
to use live animals of course you have
to justify what you are doing to be very
clearly and you should not constrain the
animal to a level which is higher than
might and also those paper gives a
description that you should use a title
approach when you are working the blind
live animals you start with non animal
and that is like webinars like DVDs
maybe you can switch to work and then
finally you will use lines and of course
you should not deliver this kind of
course to a bachelor level where many
many people will probably not use animal
later on so this is really focused on
people who are working mainly with
animals for their research and finally
it's also important that the quality of
course is maintained and as I
demonstrated with these
kind of dis table where you can design
different courses in the multiple way
you have to be sure that the quality of
the course is here because it will be
helpful for the mobility of the search
and in the yield system of approval of
application should be implemented in the
different countries or over countries
like the palazzo excitation system does
it will give confidence on the quality
of the training and assessment and so it
will introduce some confidence in the
comparing the competent authorities and
they will accept process from other
countries more easily if there is an
excitation system in place and of course
method acceptance will have mobility
there is a platform that has been
established the European level for chain
sharing and exchanging information
between the key stakeholders involved in
these education and training which are
member states authorities of course the
course provider and the application
approval of bodies and this is
illustrated by this slide which again is
not very clear but you see on the top
the member states on the bottom of the
course organizer in between the
application bodies who can be private
public international national and all
these people are sharing their knowledge
their experience and probably will try
to figure out different schemes to
ensure that of the quality of the
process is at top level and this is the
aim of this headless cut so just I will
switch now on the fellows augmentation
system and as I said already at the
start of my talk fellows are played
I'm a role in the quality control of
Education in training and they started
right away at the international level
for promoting I research research of
mobility even if the Europe is smaller
than the United States we have many
countries and it's of course it's
doesn't facilitate mobility across
borders so I will concentrate on our
2015 recommendations which can be found
on the fellows our website under
excitation go to education and training
and you can you can download this paper
and you can also see the number of
course who have been treated by our so
what kind of course do we admit and in
the learning process described in the
new paper we are really at the start of
the whole learning process
no lecture position to so the idea in
our application is to work it at the
start when the people get the first
training we are requesting pass
assessment and we provide in the courses
all we accredit courses which are
providing basic skills to to get started
in welfare and safe manner when you are
interacting with
revengeance and again if we take the
plum taxonomy we need concentrate so the
course organizer will concentrate the
learning outcomes on the knowledge
comprehension and very
slightly on the application of the
knowledge in practical life of animal
experimentation so I just want to speak
about modularity suppose we do
accreditation so of course the functions
are the wine who had been defined by the
directive but what we do is we do not an
excitation of sin modules so usually
what we want is to have a focus
including
community means of course one or several
prerequisite function and of course this
is specifically focused on one species
or a small group of species this was
really what we wanted at the start by
experience we are opening a little bit
the application to some standalone
modules and these modules 9 10 and 11
for example are concentrating on ethics
and the fears for module 9 10 and 11
constitute on the biostatistics which
can be thought the sport in in in a
standalone you don't hear you don't use
live animals for this so we do some
excitation of this kind of mobiles and
then we go to more transpacific modules
and which are devoted to surgery to
anesthesia energies on the issue of
using live animals so we are more in
favor of using the live animal for
teaching basic skill that it's very
important and I hope I will present some
data on this and we are also open to
something tonight are doing teaching
this is a bit more tricky but or not
this is a matter of how people are
working and presenting their practical
means and so this is a long-standing
issue and just here for historical
reason in 2002 the idea to use in favor
of this because probably will also
contribute to the culture of care to
develop the appropriate attitudes toward
to order this is crucial in the
publication in training science and
experimentation and also when we are
looking back to the to the courses that
we had equipment the feedback of the
participant is always very very positive
about the practical program and it gives
also some strength to still acquisition
when you in the morning you have some
principal or some theoretical course
speaking about stress about injecting
substances etc and then in the afternoon
you have to practice the skills it gives
a good translation of principle into
praxis and then to have a professional
laburnums lab animal science educational
environment to skill acquisition is very
more than I think it is clearly
different from a research environment
where people have seen Tribune's data at
high speed so these are the three
reasons and here we have told the
pictures not very good but survey on
Swiss courses we're about here how many
people were interviewed about the news
of the three first diagrams you see
strong disagreement about three
statements one the first money discourse
raised some ethical problems by using
live animals seeing that people are not
too much concerned by these ethical
concerns which can be I was
uncomfortable to know that the animals
I trained would be killed and in the end
of the of the course again quite a lot
of people are not feeling uncomfortable
and the last one the cause rates some
discomfort fearful a phobia by using
lava this is clearly not the case and
the second to last one which see a
strong agreement by the statement of the
use of live animal facilitates
significant progress in my skills and
the course made me more aware of the
issue of animal welfare with more than
80 percent of agreement which is I think
a very good sign that the use of live
animal is something which can be useful
for implementation of the three roles
and the culture of care I just shorten
review of what kind of skills we are
considering
mutation schemes or gentling handling
waiting straining clinical examination
sex in which we are speaking of some
observation these are the skill that was
always species-specific oriented and we
are considering these as acceptable for
application for the minor invasive
procedures so this is depend of the
species but IP circuit aeneas
intramuscular depending on the species X
is acceptable baburaj is optional and
then for the biological sample Iranian
paces collection and that something in
special thing is something that is
acceptable and also what we are asking
to the applicant to our application
scheme is that that the clothes manager
is providing copy of the project
optimization and how the project was
evaluated by external board for example
the CEO should also provide information
how the use of live animal is introduced
by and also demonstrate convincing
implementation of triage in this
practical because we are asking from
where all the animals coming from and
what is their fate and finally we are
also asking get a very detailed guide of
practical skills and show that the
teaching environment and may be a kind
of a practical detail but which is quite
important for a competent authorities is
that the certificate clearly in that
identified person the dates ecocide
being cross provider and also did a good
description of the course by listening
the model which species have been
and manipulated and what kind of
handling of and procedures these animals
have gotten and then there is a
depository of this certificate which is
a way to protect against potential
potential limitations and also very
often people are losing their
certificate and they're asking everybody
where this certificate is and has
central database the database just for
the quality control very briefly what we
are doing we are doing a to process
excitation first is a full course
documentation review that the applicant
has to send to the board and usually
[Music]
after one year we do an on-site course
visit audit where we are looking into
some describe so the scheme is simple
quite straight forward the application
is sent to the board the board is
checking the the tapirs very often we
have many questions so it goes back to
the applicant when it is accepted as a
critic relation the people can issue
certificate and they have to provide
each year and any report and in the new
year after activation we do build it
pass and fail if failure then the course
has to stop the issue from the list on
the website so the the quality control
is located at review of the application
is also review during the audit and also
during
I will report and the excitation is
valid for five years and of course these
can be renewed after primaries so just
for the application templates so we ask
out some general information how
qualification and entry of the course
how the information is provided to
potential participant we are also asking
of course topics and learning outcome
how what are the methods used for the
cost presentation of the learning
outcomes assess who is - teachers their
CV and very important also is to put in
place a student evaluation of the course
where the cause of analyzer has to the
duties evaluation and to put in place
actions plan to correct what is not
going well in the course so the only
report basically is to monitor if there
is any change from from the start and
again they are asking some information
general information what has changed in
the course what didn't work in the codes
cause what are the change in the
teaching staff what are the feedback of
the students and with action report and
also we review and we put in essential
data banks all set and finally for the
for the audit easily to people from the
board are going outside do a visit where
they get documentation before to to
analyze and then they attend one lecture
or one cause plus the practicals which
are very important for the for the
assessment and we are meeting old
stakeholders former students current
students that had teachers to have
did overview of how the course is going
on and finally the issue commendation in
recommendations to be mandatory just
down briefly our board is made of eight
people who are coming from different
countries in Europe so we are trying a
large sample of a different culture from
the south of Europe to the north of
Europe and so we have started audit in
2006 so just now the last part of my
talk which concerned mostly supervision
and competence so as said in the
directed the staff must be adequately
educated and trained and that they shall
be supervised into performance of their
tasks hunting they have demonstrated
acquisitive competence and again if we
go to the scheme we see that the fellows
occupation stops at reading at the early
stage of the product position of
competence and what I will speak about
now is not under the scope of fellows
are in terms of of quality control and
expectation but I will concentrate of
continuing professional development I
think to have a basic knowledge to work
under supervision plus to have
continuous training during the during
the whole carrier brings up competence
to acquire implement and I will base my
paper issued by Eleazar by working group
on Culinary Education which has been
issued in 2010
so there are of course too aims to CPD
the first one is to reach and tip for
competence by a lifelong systematic
learning which is really as good reward
of their our professional life but they
also in addition to this personal
benefit it's also to make sure that new
technologies are implemented in the
practice clearly well in place in the
institution and this that the concern of
societies are also discussed integrated
in the practice and this will
demonstrate to the competent authorities
that the welfare of animal is maintained
to optimal best practices to to to best
practices ensure so the mother a short
survey by the working group on the CPD
in 2010 so it's a little bit old but
nothing didn't change so drastically
since then so there is only few EU
countries which have a scheme in place
and just to mention that the directive
doesn't impose a CPD in the regulation
so this is open to every country and
every person which has been interviewed
saying that CPD is clearly needed about
the assessment what is a good CPD
training is about 8 to 16 hours to year
but ventilated on a period of 5 years
and of course it should update all new
technologies new trailer changes in
regulation progress in the free or
and many people think that the
naturalization light process is needed
to have a good quality job of CBB
programs so people working live animals
all should receive a CPD from this is
also clearly stated and the topics do
not include only animal experimentation
procedures but should also of course
involve the housing the breeding
especially with genetically modified
animals this is quite important and also
what concerned biostatistics and
designing and planning experiment and
then another important dimension is
their hands on to maintain ultimate
progress in the schedule also very
ordered CBD should start actually right
after the first lab animal science
course this is obvious and incident when
you stop working in this field and each
institution should have each person
field this is what clear and the
diversity and flexibility in the large
and this can involve conferences lecture
personal studies acquisition of skills
in another lab to have also professional
activities then through lavender Science
Association to follow up PhD students
this should be included in a CPD scheme
and depending on the side of the
institution think it's quite important
that these small institution
are going together to build up courses
to get the critical mass and to maintain
adequate quality I think it's quite
important in Switzerland there are very
small country and very rapidly we
coordinated between the different
universities in Switzerland and we
actually provide at least a two-day CPD
each year at the national level met
maintenance of total value is something
quite boring but you have to take care
of this to be sure that people have the
duty training and the number of credit
at the optimal level and this is
something that institution has returned
and it's actually so as I said diversity
of topics is very important it's to get
a very large view of the field of your
practice and good balance between
practical hands-on and theoretical
activities is welcome and usually the
rule found is that one hour of CPD
counts as one credit and the fellows are
has made the kind of scaling of a
commutation of credit for functionally
10 credits per year would be adequate
for function being 15 and for function C
and D applying actually a is applying
for see difference and it means to plan
and design procedures and project
pungency
is under caretaker and function D is
this function and each individual should
maintain
so to have to maintain a good quality of
CPD you have different kind of
evaluation of these programs going from
recognition to accreditation with
[Music]
different kind of quality control on
these courses and we are not yet that
application at least at Colossae level
and i will give you an example of
endorsement system in in switzerland and
of course you should always that the
quality of your CPD to the aims that the
institution and people have to achieve
and it is always very good to obviously
the portfolio's to review the objectives
you can have been achieved and to do a
good communication with the company and
other stakeholders just very briefly on
the Swiss example it's probably not the
best but it's quite simple and quite
transparent so it's really based on it's
a process based system so there is not
20 control of learning outcomes of these
courses but it is really engineered
driven process and quite importantly the
competent authorities and invest a lot
of time and money not money in these
simple schemes and so there is a basis
in the law which makes continuing
education mandatory for everybody
working with we will live animals with
elaborately experimental animals and the
description of this continuing education
is also giving in
an article article 50 the continued
education may take place in the form of
a course of some hands-on and also when
you attend to Congress or workshop and
it's quite interesting that not only
specific in functions are concerned but
also the animal classically managers and
member of the ethical boards who are
evaluating the project had to achieve
CPD and when you are organizing such a
course
you mean submitted to the competent
authorities which is the Swiss
Association of the state veterinarian
and there is a official forum where you
will describe the content to whom it is
and and other details and you have also
to provide an evaluation form by
participant of the course so that are
the competent authorities can have a
check on how the course has been
conceived and evaluated by the
participant and we also to provide the
template of certificate or other of
attendance even in the Swiss law you
have really template which is described
maybe the interest here it has to to
show that you have to provide clear idea
of the people an idea of the training
course and a signature of who has given
up the course and in Switzerland you
keep the right perform animal explain as
long as you have attended continuously
for days of CPD for the last four years
so you have always to keep in your last
four years with four days of CPD which
correspond to four times six hours of of
course of the contents to a meeting and
you have a federal IT system which two
tracks of the CPD training of everybody
in animal experimentation validated by
the reminding so to conclude I would say
that article 23 of the directly had
taken now education and training
mandatory in all 28 member states so
this is quite a change since 2010
modules and their associated learning
outcomes make the pedagogical approach
flexible and diverse by aiming through
the output instead of the process of
course with a risk of lack of
harmonization between institution that
regional and Country level because some
states some countries have different
view of how you can achieve learning
outcomes and there is a small but I
think by excitation by endorsement and
submission process in place learning
education and training will still high
quality the quality will be maintained
if we put in place education processes
forever has played a minor role in this
supranational quality control and I
think it will still play a key role in
the future to facilitate mobility of
people between research institution and
CPD and supervision this is another part
which I didn't touch upon should be the
next challenges of janaba in science the
lab animal science European community
and by this slide I would like to finish
this presentation and thank you very
much for your attention
well thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we're gonna try
to answer as many questions as we can
our first question is can you apply the
thulsa accreditation before launching a
new course or after a few runs you can
apply for application of the first
course in the past we had two rounds but
now we decree it to one run one of the
reason is that you have to fine-tune
your course and also what we want to
have is the feedback of the students to
see how the course has been perceived by
the participants so the rule now is one
course run before application and then
you submit
thank you
and our next question is can I apply for
such accreditation even if I'm not a
member of philosopher
with India we have a tennis excitation
in Chennai in India where these people
were interested to get this application
the difference is actually in the price
of these accreditation in Europe or in
the philosophy munity the audit is paid
actually by the fee the annual thing
plus the pinna debt is bound to each
certificate issues issued for all these
Indian cost you the people have to pay
the auditors a travel and accommodation
accommodation this is the only
difference
and how much does accreditation cost
yeah I didn't mention this so the the
application cost of currently 440 euros
per year and plus seven year old her
certificate issued and actually you when
the Kosovan Iser is interested in this
and get the excitation then signed a
contract between his institutional
horror institution and aunt Eliza and
usually this contract allows for five
years so it's in some way it's quite a
cheap imitation but we are covering the
cost by period of five years and I
remind the people that we are not paid
for this application this is maybe
voluntary and based activities are quite
demanding activity and I like to thank
my colleagues on the board on the board
because it's it's quite a huge amount of
work but we are it's okay we are even in
our account
my course is in French and I finished it
do I have to translate all of my
documents into English and a good
question yeah sorry yeah it's a good
question especially in Europe Greece
from Portugal
so what we are asking is that equitation
application is in English but the
closest have not been do not have to be
translated in English we are asking for
some specific question on the evaluation
that we can read this but the course in
itself is not is not needed in English
of course it looks like we have
time for one last question here doctor
how many courses are philosoph president
in Europe and elsewhere 30 courses now
who are repeated in in Europe including
this one in India so this is the only
one that is out of you and thank you and
doctor before we let you go today do you
have any final closing comments well
what so what I would recommend is of
course
conclusion but I think with these EU
directives in place I think this is a
very very useful scheme to increase
quality of animal experimentation and
implementation I think this is really a
key activity to have animal
experimentation which is acceptable
again I would like to thank dr. a Marcel
Geiger for his outstanding presentation
I'll also like to thank our sponsor
labyrinth for making today's educational
webcasts possible today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through April 2017 you'll receive an
email from labret saluting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to colleagues who've may have missed
today's live event and until next time
goodbye